In this problem, a proposed air
pollution control device has the
following particulate size distribution
and collection efficiencies.
If the overall collection efficiency of
the device is 82%,
what must be the collection efficiency
for the 11 to 20 micrometer size range?
So the following particulate size
distributions are given here in the
table from 0 to 10, 11 to 20, 21 to 50.
And we can see that the percent in each
size fraction of the total is given
here. And the device efficiency is given
here.
So we know the capture efficiencies for
the smallest and largest fractions 55
and 92%.
But the middle size is unknown.
So today's problem is all about weighted
efficiency in an air pollution control
device.
But instead of giving you every number,
we're going to solve for the one that's
missing using the total efficiency
provided. So here's how we approach it.
Overall efficiency is just the weighted
sum of each fraction multiplied by its
own efficiency.
So we take the percentages, convert them
to decimals, and multiply them by their
respective efficiencies and set the
whole equation equal to 82% or 0.82.
So let's do that. Now
for our first range, we are going to do
0.2* 2
times 55% is 0.55
plus
the weight of the second range or rather
the percent in the size fraction of the
second range is 0.25
times an unknown efficiency of X
plus the third particulate size range.
The percent size is 0.55
times the control device efficiency of
92% or 0.92.
And all of this is equal to 82% or 0.82.
So if we do the math out, we can
simplify this pretty quickly.
and then subtracting out each side.
And finally dividing by 25 will give us
x equ=
0.816
or
81.6%.
And our closest answer is the fourth one
over here.
So the takeaway here is simple.
Even if a size range is relatively small
or a relatively small portion of the
total, in this case just 25%.
It may still require a pretty high
efficiency to pull the overall
performance
up to the target level of 82%.
Even when the other large percentage of
size fraction here has a very high
efficiency as well.
Um, it might also seem weird that the
answer for our particulate size range is
the same number as the overall
collection efficiency.
Sometimes that's just how the math
works. And try not to let it fake you
out. It'll either be unintentional or
another intentional mind game that the
PE plays on you. And that's it. This is
just a weighted average problem.